You guys seen that, uh, first of all,
have you seen the, uh,
the Venmo or the, um, XXX pentacene thing?
Uh, I don't remember the names of either parties involved that started it.
I actually don't know if I knew some comedian named Dena made this joke or
Dyna made this joke on comedy central about the, uh,
slain rapper. And, uh,
it was a joke, you know,
and then I think James Davis comedian was comedian that originally
said this is offensive or something. And, um,
I don't really know enough about it,
but I just saw that the fallout of it and everyone was like
outro. There were a lot of XXX,
10 Tassian fans that were sending death threats
to the, the,
the comedian that did it and comedy central retracted it.
And I guess apologized for it.
And the whole thing about the whole thing,
I just have to say no about the whole thing,
because here are the things. If comedy is comedy,
if there is comedy,
then you just you're allowed to just make whatever joke there is.
And you're just going to offend some people. And that's not a bad thing.
That's a good thing because that's what makes comedy comedy,
all jokes are offensive to somebody. Otherwise it's not even a joke, dude.
If I make a, if I make a joke about somebody's refrigerator, I say,
I just refrigerate. It sucks because of this, whatever, the Vulcan joke.
That's a hilarious joke by the way. But if it was even funnier than that,
somebody be like, ah, that's. That's my refrigerator go yourself.
It's because it's going to be offensive to somebody or the person's not going to
give a, whatever, but it's like, you can't pick and choose,
especially as a comedian,
you can't call out another comedian for making fun of first of
all, it was a joke, regardless of whether or not you think it was good.
It was a joke. It was in joke form. I think the joke was something like, um,
rat, rapper, existent Tessio,
and God got killed for carrying $50,000 on his person.
I'm butchering the joke, but, uh, that's the best Venmo commercial ever, right?
Don't care where your cash is. Use Venmo, whatever the joke was.
I don't know what it was funnier than that, but, um, yeah,
it does a joke and to say, Oh,
as a comedian, you can't. Yeah. You can't say that. that.
Then you're not, you're not really a comedian.
Uh, because you know what, I, I saw other people on, on Twitter as like,
yeah, it's the fact that it, wasn't funny. That's the offensive part.
You don't get to pick. You can personally say, that's not funny for me,
but if comedy Central's going to put something out there, they already did that.
You can't take it. Apparently they took it off the internet and they're like,
we're sorry. They're not, they're not, uh,
taking it off the internet because they're because of they're
taking off the internet because the mob is why they're taking off the internet.
That's not okay because people are going to be offended.
I mean, for sake, the joke really wasn't even that offensive.
If you said the about Michael Jackson, nobody would give a if he said the. And,
and, and,
and he's got all these alleged things about how he beat up his pregnant
girlfriend or whatever, you know, and you know,
I know it was never proven in a court of law, but neither was the Jackson.
But it's just like, why, you know,
it's because of his rabid fan base. I think, dude, let me just tell you.
If people make jokes about me, just if I ever get to the level where, you know,
people are just like slamming me or whatever, it's all good babies.
You don't need to tell people to go kill themselves. It's all good man. Jokes.
It's intent. It's this and that. I get it. But like, dude,
we're allowed to make all the jokes and we're allowed to go too far because
that's how we figure out what jokes are funny. And that's how you keep pushing.
That's why stuff, listen, man, listen.
That's why stuff that was made in 1930.
Isn't funny anymore because we've advanced beyond that.
If you don't keep pushing the envelope,
we'll be stuck with Laurel and Hardy, dude,
they'll be trying to push a piano up the stairs. And we'll be like
the whole reason why funny now is because you have the people that will push
that envelope.
And I'm not saying Laurel and Hardy, isn't funny, but we're past that dude.
We're past that because of people who make jokes like the one on comedy central,
whether you think it's funny or not, you have to figure it out.
You got to push it.
Otherwise you're going to be the Dick had that still laughing at,
you know, whatever it is in black and white at the thing,
dude stuff. Isn't funny 60 years later because of that.
So if you're, especially if you're a comedian, dude, go to war for the comedian.
I don't care if you like the guy's music. Look, I thought the guy's music,
I'm not a fan of the guy, but the guy's music was incredible. I liked his music.
You know, he's a talented guy.
You can't say he's not talented just because of what his person was like.
But dude,
the whole thing is insane.
I just, you know,
there's countless things in my set that could, you know,
catch fire and be like, ah, this is that they said this, that he said that,
but it's just the story of the day.
So shout out who was the comedian that said the joke, Dinah, what?
Dina Hasham. Don't worry. You know,
I know you're getting slaughtered by [inaudible] fans,
but it's going to be fine. You know,
it's so to tell people to go kill themselves online. It's so, dude,
grow the up, grow up.
And if you're 13 for real grow up because like, dude,
you're going to look back at yourself and you're going to be like, Oh,
I shouldn't have done that.
I'm a Laurel and Hardy watcher in 2019, dude,
go watch some Yuk. Yuks push a piano up a flight of stairs. You stupid.
That's a good, that would be a good insult in my head. If I was arguing with a,
you know, kick. But now I said it. So I can't use it anymore.
It's just like, dude, get it together, man.
It's so it's so annoying, dude. I tried to follow Dana on, on,
on, on Twitter. So, you know, I had to ask,
she cause you now she's private because she doesn't want people coming up to her
saying, they're going to see people online saying, go kill yourself. Dude. Also,
how about the fact that, Hey, don't,
don't make jokes about someone who is killed or will kill you.
[Inaudible].
You idiot. Do you realize what you're doing? You dumb.
You can. It's not America. If you can't say whatever you want to say, you know,
I say this to my act. You can get mad at somebody for saying something,
but you can't tell them not to say it.
Uh, so yeah, by the way, it was a Venmo joke. It wasn't a XX.
Exten Tachyon joke. It was a Venmo joke.
So you're getting offended at a Venmo joke. You.
You're getting offended at a Venmo joke. All good?
All good,
go watch some guys who looked different than each
other.
Push up a piano on a, on a flight of stairs.
You, you know.
Which is so lame.
Got a hobby, got a sunglasses hut, get some,
Arnett's put them on, get some gel
and go drive a Acura Integra around in 1998.
Now that's a slam. It's a lot of words,
but it is a slam and you have walked into Denny's and I'm so sorry.
But all we have right now are the great a all American slams.
That's what we have. Here you go. Eat it while I go like this.